طائرات الكوايت كابتر تقوم باطلاق نار
بالقرب من مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير
البلاح حيث كما تشاهدون المواطنون يبدا
باخلاء
المنطقه لان ايضا هناك في هذه المنطقه
وهذا المحور حيث شارع صلاح الدين الرئيسي
في هذه الصوره يبعد عشرات الامتار عن
مستشفى شهداء الاقصى قبل قليل
ال للدبابات الاسرائيليه وهي تسير على
شارع صلاح الدين بالقرب من منطقه المصدر
وعلى شارع الشارع المؤدي لمستشفى شهداء
الاقصى في دير البلح وسط قطاع
غزه الان ايضا اصابات تصل مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى في هذه الاوقات
جراء القصف الاسرائيلي من الطائرات كابتر
التي تطلق النار وتطلق النار باتجاه
المواطنين في مناطق متفرقه من دير البلح
قبل
قليل الان اصابات ايضا تصل مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى جراء اطلاق النار من طائرات الكوات
كابتر الاسرائيليه على المواطنين في محيط
المستشفى